Il fait actuellement 34°
Ma peau risque de suinter tel une limace *[Son"SPLATCH"]*
Bon j'avoue faire les courses c'est vraiment un thème bien gentil et bien banal
On dirait un peu Oui-Oui qui fait un podcast
Je sais pas si vous avez remarqué mais quand on fait les courses au pays des jouets...*[klaxon de la voiture de Oui-Oui"bip bip bip"et... "BOOOOM!"*
Mais en même temps faire les courses, c'est bien d'en parler parce que c'est vraiment un truc de la vie quotidienne qu'on fait tous
Et surtout un moment de convivialité
*Pleurs de bébé + musique de magasin*
FAUX !
Alors évidemment dans un magasin y'a plein de marques hein c'est la vie. Alors si vous voyez une marque dans cette vidéo
C'est pas un placement de produit...
C'est plutôt 50 000 placements de produit, gratuits
Je sais pas vous... mais moi quand je fais mes courses
C'est toujours la même routine
À chaque fois, je fais une petite liste de courses bien propre...
...que j'oublie
Je prends toujours le paquet au fond de la pile
Histoire de gagner deux jours de péremption
Y'a toujours ce mec planté pile poil devant là où tu veux prendre un produit
J'ai toujours envie de mettre le truc du caddie dans la fente comme si les inventeurs n'y avait jamais pensé
Je vois toujours quelqu'un que je connais, mais je fais semblant de ne pas le connaître
Et enfin, je prends toujours la queue la plus rapide qui devient la moins rapide
Alors, j'sais pas non plus comment vous vous comportez au magasin
Mais moi, je pense que je ne suis pas toujours le client idéal
Quand je fais tomber un produit et qu'y a pas de témoins
Bah, je ramasse pas
J'aime bien reposer les produits au mauvais endroit
J'essaie toujours de passer à la caisse moins de 10 articles avec 11
Parfois, je mange un produit avant de l'avoir payé
Et je suis en stress comme si j'avais braqué une banque
*Sirène de police*
Et puis à la pesée, pour payer moins cher,
J'ai toujours envie de mettre l'étiquette d'un autre produit
*Caissière* Vous êtes sûr que c'est des bananes, ça ?
Oui
C'est des bananes rondes... de la Réunion
Bon, à part ça
J'vous rassure, hein, j'suis un client honnête
Mais quand je sors du magasin sans avoir rien acheté
J'ai toujours peur que le mec de la sécu croit que j'ai volé un truc
*Musique de film d'horreur*
Euh , finalement, j'ai rien acheté, je...
*Musique de film d'action*
*Sécurité* Code 43, code 43[avec bruit d'alarme]
Quand y'a une dégustation, j'sais pas si c'est parce que c'est gratuit
Mais j'ai toujours l'impression que c'est le meilleur fromage au monde
Hmm, encore un petit
Je peux me permettre? *Employée* Mais allez-y
On dirait qu'il vous plaît
Il est à 15 €
Ah non, je l'aime pas trop en fait
Merci
À chaque fois, à la caisse
J'sais pas si vous faites pareil
Mais moi, je regarde les gens
Et en fonction des produits qu'ils achètent, j'imagine leur vie
*pensée* D'accord, donc elle dans la vie, sa passion, c'est le pâté
Donc lui ce soir a mon avis il a un petit date et il compte bien conclure
Elle, elle doit être en pleine rupture amoureuse, genre je mange du ice cream devant Bridget Jones
Ah ouais, alors lui, il lui manquait juste un truc pour aller aux toilettes
A mon avis, il en peut plus là
En parlant de PQ, vous allez encore trouver ça ridicule
Mais moi, même à 30 ans, j'assume toujours pas d'acheter du PQ
En fait, j'ai peur de me faire interpeller par quelqu'un
*Inconnu* Putain, Norman fait des vidéos, mais qu'est-ce tu fous là?
Ben là, je fais du hockey sur glace
*Inconnu* Tu fais du hockey sur quoi ?
Non, je déconne, c'est une blague
*Inconnu* Du coup, on peut prendre une petite photo?
Ben si, ça me dérange pas
YOU SUCK!!!
À la caisse, quand tes produits sont sur le tapis
Et que tu te rends compte que t'as oublié un truc
Soit tu laisses tomber, c'est trop tard
Ou soit tu pars en Mission Impossible
*Pensée* Merde, j'oublié les oeufs
J'ai oublié un truc, je reviens, pardon, euh j'arrive
Il est où le rayon, bordel ?
Non mais qu'est-ce qu'il fait là ?
*Musique heavy metal*
Bon, il est toujours pas revenu
Client suivant, bonjour !
NOOOON ! *Explosion*
Au fait, il faut dire aux caissiers et aux caissières
Que remplir les sacs et payer, c'est vraiment 2 actions qu'on peut pas faire en même temps
La pression est toujours totale !
35 €, s'il vous plaît
Déjà tu galères et en plus, t'as un public
Toute la file te regarde vénère
*Client* Sérieux putain, il sait pas ouvrir un sac
Quelqu'un a de la salive?
Alors des fois au supermarché, ils te proposent des caisses automatiques
Bon déjà, elle te parle comme à un maternelle avec le son bien fort
Tout le monde entend que tu galères
*Caisse* Posez votre article sur la plateforme
*Caisse* Non, pas cet article-là, tu es con ou quoi?
*Caisse* Veuillez passer votre article devant le scanner
*Caisse* C'est simple pourtant, regarde, tout le monde autour de toi y arrive
*Caisse* Un assistant va venir vous aider
*pleurs*
Et vu comment à chaque fois, c'est un échec
Je me dis : la caisse automatique, elle porte bien son nom, hein
À chaque fois que tu l'utilises, automatiquement, t'as besoin d'une vraie caissière
La solution, c'est peut-être de faire ses courses en ligne
Bon, moi j'ai déjà essayé, c'est pratique, hein, mais ça a ses limites
*Copine* Ah non,  y'a plus rien à manger
T'inquiètes, je m'occupe de tout, je commande en ligne
Voilà, on mange mercredi entre 17h et 19h
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo !
J'espère que maintenant quand vous irez faire vos courses, eh ben, vous vous sentirez moins seul
Et puis, il faut relativiser hein, dans la préhistoire, nos ancêtres
Ils partaient faire les courses avec des lances et ils étaient pas sûrs de revenir vivants
Maintenant, tu peux acheter des produits des 4 coins du monde en 2 secondes à côté de chez toi
On a plus franchement les mêmes problèmes
Ah, ça me saoule, je pète un cable, il faut pas me parler
J'ai pas trouvé le rayon sans gluten
Comment je vais me nourrir? Tu m'expliques? T'as une réponse? Tu me l'envoies sur Whatsapp?
Si vous avez aimé, n'oubliez pas de mettre un petit Thumb to the Top in the Shine
Ça veut rien dire
Grace a la "nouvelle" mise a jour youtube quand vous cliquez , ici, là, sur ce bouton,
Depuis un téléphone ou un ordi, bah ça fait un truc nouveau.
Allez y essayez cliquez... Avec votre doigt ou votre souris !
Voila !
Pas mal , non ? Plutot cool, hyper simple pour s'abonner, beaucoup plus instinctif.
Donc Merci Monsieur Youtube et puis merci a vous
Je vous aime énormément ! Lachez un ptit pouce en l'air svp ! Au revoir.